400000 drones de loisirs ont été vendus
en france en 2010 7 mai à l'origine
saviez vous que ce drôle d'engin était
destiné à des fins militaires
les premiers prototypes sont apparus au
début du 20e siècle
mais c'est dans les années 1990 que
l'armée française a développé les drones
cet appareil n'est pas une maquette mais
un véritable avion espion
un drone français le crécerelle
l'émission des drones militaires sont
diverses recherches de renseignement
localisation de cibles cartographie
l'armée lancée même un concours en 2004
trouver les drones de demain l'enjeu
les drones de plus en plus petits voici
l'un des projets les plus prometteurs le
cp x4 bourré d'électronique
il traverse pièces et couloirs la dg à a
donné une subvention de 40 mille euros à
des étudiants pour réaliser cet étrange
hélicoptère qui peut même observer en
douce les délibérations du jury
jusque là utilisées par l'armée le drone
va connaître un usage civil à la fin des
années 2000 en 2010 l'entreprise parrot
spécialisé dans les produits de haute
technologie lance le premier drone
entièrement contrôlée par un smartphone
l'aer drones un joujou high-tech 100%
français
son concepteur espère d'abord séduire
les fans de jeux vidéo
caméra embarquée micro intégré ou encore
récupération de données
le drone n'est pourtant pas un jouet
comme les autres la question de
l'atteinte à la vie privée se pose alors
nous sommes ici dans un placement de
paris dans un espace public et dégagé on
pourrait croire que c'est un lieu
approprié pour faire voler un drone
or il n'en est rien si vous venez ici
après noël avec votre jouet ou un drone
de plus grande taille vous encourez
potentiellement un an de prison 75000
euros d'amendé
il n'est pas le bienvenu dans l'espace
public du coup les courses de drones
sont organisés et réglementées comme ici
aux etats-unis en 2016 et attention
accrochez vos ceintures
chaque pilote est relié à son drop par
casque caméra c'est comme s'il était
installé dans le cockpit de son petit
pauline volant avec pour seul avantage
de ne pas perdre la vie dans le dropt ce
crash en mille morceaux 11,2 milliards
d'euros
c'est ce que devrait atteindre le marché
des drones en 2020 d'après le cabinet
gartner
un chiffre qui comprend le civil mais
aussi le professionnel agriculture
livraison produits ou de médicaments le
drone du futur encore de beaux jours
devant lui
[Musique]